as a child growing up in Indiana in the
Midwest I saw this movie
then I could count I was an
african-american child obviously in a
family of ten kids my mother my father
my grandmother 13 of us living in a
3-bedroom trailer and we were the only
African American family for miles around
and so I understood the black and white
notion the black and white tension that
existed in this film and indeed in my
own community some years ago and so I
saw this movie countless times as a
child I always felt then not knowing
much about the Hollywood process that
you could not make a movie that was more
perfectly cast I felt that as a child
growing up in Indiana but when I use
later moved to Los Angeles after college
to work for the late great mayor and the
first and all the african-american mayor
to date of this city Tom Bradley I yes I
had the occasion to meet Gregory Peck
and Brock Peters countless times they
were both dear friends of the mayor and
had many times to sit and to talk with
him and to pick their brains and to to
get to know them just a wee bit and once
I got to know them in my own way as
Friends of the mayor I really came to
understand how perfectly cast this movie
really was because the one thing that
Gregory Peck and Brock Peters did not
have to act out was their humanity and I
was so delighted as you often know I'm I
won't call names but I do this every day
so sometimes you meet people and they
are not as advertised shall we say in
this town and so I was quite delighted
to know that the man who I'd come to
know on-screen in this brilliant classic
film were as advertised their humanity
was something they did not have to act
out and as I look back on it now it gave
me a brand-new working definition of
what it means in this town to be a true
authentic character actor I think this
film reminds us of a number of things I
was caught in a number of conversations
in the lobby prior to making it in here
and more than one person said to me in
his or her own way
with regard to the relevance of this
film 50 years later what are the chances
no matter what you think of the case no
matter the outcome it as we get it
started a national conversation this
killing of Trayvon Martin in Florida and
what are the chances that 50 years later
as we sit here in Beverly Hills to
screen this classic film about the black
and white tension that has existed for
so long in this country what are the
chances that this day in Florida George
Zimmerman would have been arrested what
are the chances that we sit here tonight
to watch this film all these years later
about that tension sadly that still
exists in our country what I celebrate
about Hollywood at its best let me
underscore that what I celebrate
celebrate that is about Hollywood at its
best is that the killer mockingbird
reminds us that films don't just have to
entertain they can do more than
entertain they can entertain and they
can empower and they can inspire and
they can elevate the discourse in this
country when you see a film like the
Kill a Mockingbird you get reminded that
Hollywood oftentimes is so focused on
monetizing that we forget about
humanizing and this film underscores
that we can both monetize and humanize
at the same time this movie as you well
know set against the backdrop of the
segregated south it celebrates the power
of good in the face of evil or as I like
to say simply put it celebrates that
love wins love wins thanks to one of the
most cherished books in all of American
literature the film adaptation of Harper
Lee's magnum opus also gives us one of
the great movie heroes of our time is
the president under the other day
Atticus Finch played with sublime
strength by Gregory Peck Atticus Finch
became the living embodiment of the core
values that will under attack in this
country
in the age of Jim Crow and might I add
Jane crow what it must have meant back
in 1962 to Negroes
as we were called in what it must have
meant back in 1962 to here Peck as
Atticus Finch say to his daughter scout
you never really understand a person
until you consider things from his point
of view until you climb inside his skin
and walk around in it it's no wonder
then that this powerful formulation and
the generation it inspired helped make
Atticus Finch the greatest movie hero of
the 20th century according to the
American Film Institute
and speaking of scalp how honored we are
this evening as Ellen mentioned to
welcome the woman whose brilliant
portrayal not only earned her an Oscar
nomination but allowed all of us to
consider the profound loss of innocence
as seeing through the eyes of a child in
1962 the New York Times described her as
a superb discovery and I couldn't agree
more
Mary madam we love you with the life
that you hear again with us tonight
I also want to acknowledge very quickly
as his name was mentioned earlier
because I am always humbled to be in his
presence you talk about changing the
course of history for all of us but
particularly for african-americans it is
with with great honor tonight that I
also welcome to this room one of the
Little Rock Nine dr. Terrence Roberts
dr. Roberts thank you again for being
here sir
appreciate you there are so many
memorable scenes in this movie every
time I watch it I'm hoping for some kind
of celluloid miracle when the verdict is
read but of course Tom Robinson's
wrongful conviction is central to
helping us understand the tension that
too often exists as I said earlier even
today between truth and justice for me a
black man born in that Jim Crow South in
the summer of 1964 just across the way
in Mississippi what follows the verdict
is perhaps for me the most moving part
of this entire film is that ACCA's Finch
is gathering his things to exit the
courtroom following that trial the
Negroes in the balcony all begin to rise
and pay their respect after the entire
balcony is standing there Reverend
played by that wonderful actor Bill
Walker puts his arm around scout and
says Miss Jean Louise miss Jean Louise
stand up your father is passing seeing
this black man gently put his arm around
the shoulder of this little white girl
as he helps her to understand the
respect and importance her father has in
the black community is a thing of beauty
when all is said and done to kill a
mockingbird was nominated for eight
Academy Awards taking home three
including of course Gregory pecks career
at defining role and his award when he
died in 2003 fittingly it's worth
remembering tonight that Brock Peters of
all the persons who could have been
asked to do this the Peck family in
their wisdom and their humanity
gave Brock Peters the honor of
eulogizing Gregory Peck skillfully
directed by Robert Mulligan and
featuring a superb screenplay by horton
Foote the film also marked the
unforgettable screen debut of a future
Hollywood legend without uttering a
single word he captures us with his
inner mattock but ultimately boy
character Boo Radley Robert Duvall it is
it is perhaps too much to ask or expect
that one film or even one book could
change the course of history and sadly
in the year after this film's release
Atticus Finch as Alabama became ground
zero for the other nests and the
violence of the modern civil rights era
indeed Birmingham was such a place of
violence that it was called bombing ham
decades later we see myriad examples all
around us of work not yet done and yet I
still dream a world where more of us
will find the courage the conviction the
commitment and the character to shine
lights on our society's most pressing
basic human challenges because where
there is no hope for the future there is
no power in the present ladies and
gentleman please enjoy now this
digitally restored print of an American
treasure to kill a mockingbird